[Music]
if you don't know this is Friday all
right okay solder diary aka maybe Sun
diary this week as I look back at my
weekend blog for him so here are some of
the things that happened this week I'm
like Kate Winslet in that movie where I
explained my favorite game I played in
college which I encourage you to do
which is you sing your front lawn and
lawn chairs with a sign that says you
honk we drink
hi guys happy Saturday it's a very much
of Saturday it's very much a Saturday
last night was mamrie Hart's why dad
book party it was super fun there are so
many jello shots head tomorrow I leave
to go to can France can lyon is a big
festival event convention thing that's
happening out there i went last year and
i'm going this year for a week to speak
on a bunch of panels so this is what's
happening that thing is helping me pack
[Music]
we're about to head to France
we've got given these packets Xuan they
know their audience
Air France
[Music]
very excited baby now about to get on a
flight to go back to Los Angeles it's
gonna be a crazy week very exciting
I have billions of emails that I have to
answer right now flight leaves at 7:10
a.m. I'm at the airport at 12:30 from
how let's get to editing I don't know